[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis bow wow
nicolas et pimprenelle ont été très
sages tous ces jours ci au sol pas trop
pour les récompenser nous allons leur
raconter une jolie histoire descend vite
leur montrer ton beau livre nounours tu
fonces pas trop où là que je suis bête
j'oubliais bancs d'école que je suis née
go tu ne changeras jamais mon cher nos
bons le jeune homme
[Musique]
bonsoir les gens qu'est ce que tu nous
as pas un beau livre d'image que je vais
vous montrer que notre ami le marchand
de sable va vous raconter un seuil on
nous d'abord au mais ne vous bousculez
pas comme ça là nous y sommes c'est
l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui
s'appelle
comme je n'ai pas dit dans de nonce la
drôle de nom le petit garçon lui il est
très gentil
vous allez voir vous pas trop le papa et
la maman de cornichons vendent de la
laine
il habite dans une roulotte c'est quoi
ça une roue lac
c'est une maison très jolie qui est
construite sur des roues comment il
s'appelle se peut thomas oui et dada
dire la roulotte
car ils vont vendre leur laine dans
beaucoup de pays et notre petit corniche
on est très content car il adore les
voyages c'est toujours lui qui conduit
la roulotte commission il a quand même
un drôle de nom les enfants écoutent
rechute petits cornichons conduit la
roulotte mais dada lui connaît bien tous
les chemins et il est encouragé par son
petit ami qui crie du dada et pendant ce
temps là la maman de cornichons range
ses jolies laine de toutes les couleurs
dans de grands paniers et le papa lui
joue de la guitare
dès que la roulotte arrive dans un
village notre gentil petits cornichons
des sens et des ses parents car il ya
beaucoup de gens qui d attente pour
acheter de la laine et il y a aussi
beaucoup d'enfants qui se rassemblent
ward à skis le grau d'agde 1 et voilà
une dame qui veut de la laine rouge
quand il on va chercher de la laine
rouge dans la roulotte et cornichons
apporte de la laine bleu oui mais non
encore les shows de la rouge et la
grosse dame rouge et cornichons apporte
de la laine jaune ou non alors votre
camp ifo
il est vraiment dit la grosse dame rouge
en connaît ravenhill cognition voilà
madame voilà madame dit la maman de
cornichons qui lui apporte vite de la
laine rouge et qui ne se fâche pas car
elle sait bien que son petit corniche on
est un peu dans la lune aux sahwa et
alors mais lesquels mangin ti et le soir
quand il est couché
elle embrasse très fort et son papa pour
lui faire plaisir
lui joue de la guitare
n'est pas l'histoire
il est très mignon c'est du gâteau grâce
à une icône à nathalie collin et
cornichons allons les petits hauts
totaux bonus mais petit ange j'ai fait
pour lui nicolas tard bien après neil
[Applaudissements]
aux nuits petit nicolas bonne nuit petit
apprenent elle bonne nuit tous les
enfants embrasser bien fort vos parents
allaient bien vite vous coucher est
faite de doux rêves m'ouvre aux poteaux
oui mon cher nounours allons en août
bonne nuit à demain otomo bob